this place brings back good memories
like the day i got out
speaking of i want to introduce you to
that little girl i was telling you about
izzy's gone again ah she's an escape
artist just like you
is the coast clear
[Applause]
you must be izzy oh man are you gonna
turn me in
no i'm just here to take pictures good
because i'm busting out of here i'm
punky i hold a record for busting out of
this place
well it's nice to meet you but i'm about
to break your record oh can i take a
picture before you go
i get it you want me to smile and look
cute and cuddly so somebody adopts me
not happening i'm not a puppy
i don't want you to smile everybody
smiles that's
boring look mean stomp your feet
stick out your tongue give me beyonce
girl squad diva
[Applause]
oops got you smiling
how did you become a photographer nice
man named henry took me under his wing
he saw potential in me that nobody else
did
i wish i could be a photographer you can
be anything you want to be
i don't have a camera
sure you do your eyes are your camera
and your brain is your memory card
you can take a mental picture of
anything you want and store it right up
here
click see i just took a picture of you
you try
i'm taking a selfie click
there you are man i should have ghosted
when i had the chance
come on izzy let's go
you two seem to be getting along oh i am
on to you
you thought i would fall in love with
izzy and wouldn't be able to resist
fostering her
can you just keep her for a couple days
i have a terrific family that is
interested in fostering her i just need
to get them approved and if she stays
here punky she's gonna run
i'm sorry i can't take on any more
responsibility i'm barely keeping it
together
wearing a bathing suit is underwear
right now
you